[Música]
y
sin duda costa rica es un país altamente
sísmico por la ubicación geográfica que
tenemos y por eso esta semana incluso
nosotros los ticos estamos acostumbrados
a sentir movimientos telúricos espero
que no
terremotos sismos la forma de prepararse
o de planear es a través del código
sísmico que es el código sísmico bueno
no es más que un conjunto de normas un
conjunto de buenas prácticas que tienen
como propósito fundamental que el diseño
de las obras civiles de las
edificaciones cumplan con ciertos
lineamientos básicos primero obviamente
para garantizar la vida de la gente que
va a estar ahí
en segundo lugar mantener la calidad
estructural de las edificaciones y pues
también resguardar todos los bienes que
están en las casas o que están en los
apartamentos
qué pasa si por alguna razón el código
sísmico se incumple
a alguien pensando en que supuestamente
va a tener ahorros de costos hace una
edificación y respetando estas normas o
estos lineamientos básicos o mínimos
pues sencillamente como lo vemos aquí
ante el menor movimiento telúrico la
construcción no
soporta el movimiento telúrico
correspondiente
se suponía que en mi lámina el
movimiento telúrico se iba a dar y que
el edificio se iba a caer yo aquí no lo
estoy viendo no sé si ustedes lo están
viendo si ustedes si lo vieron
no solamente el problema está que ese
que tomó la decisión de respetar un
código que es mandatorio puso en riesgo
su edificación sino que también nos
corremos el riesgo de que haya un efecto
rebote o un efecto contagio sobre otras
edificaciones que sí respetaron el
código sísmico y que se construyeron
sobre cimientos sólidos eso es lo que
nosotros en finanzas o en el sistema
financiero llamamos el riesgo sistémico
o el riesgo contagio o el efecto dominó
bueno yo he arrancado esta charla
ciencia en ingeniero estructural porque
creo que hay mucha similitud entre el
diseño estructural el código sísmico y
el diseño de la estructura del sistema
financiero en el mundo y en particular
como voy ahora a desarrollar en el caso
de costa rica
y si no recuerden la reciente crisis
global del 2008 2009 se crea una
innovación se crea un nuevo producto
denominado short prime mortgages sobre
el cual se empiezan a construir
utilizando derivados financieros
productos sintéticos conocidos como
morgan securities una serie de negocios
para crecientes pero como lo vemos acá
resulta que cuando vino el menor
movimiento telúrico que fue una pequeña
subida en las tasas de interés de esas
hipotecas que no tenían calidad y que se
habían financiado con una relación de
préstamo a valor del avalúo más del 100
por ciento pues entonces toda la
estructura de grande bleu y no solamente
se cayó el sistema de world street de
ese país en particular sino que una
crisis de carácter global que con
pérdidas millonarias y con consecuencias
sociales que aún al día de hoy estamos
nosotros experimentando
cuando roberto me invitó a esta charla
yo lo pensé en decirle que sí o que no
sobre todo por la coyuntura actual que
está pasando el país vean yo vengo a
esta presentación no a causar pánico no
va a generar miedo no va a generar temor
quiero hacer la advertencia como
participante que fui del sistema
financiero creo que es mi
responsabilidad social venir a compartir
con ustedes una serie de debilidades
estructurales que yo considero sigue
teniendo el sistema financiero pero que
aún estamos en tiempo creo yo de
corregir
dicho eso entonces voy a empezar por el
final de la película cuando le interesa
ver el final de la película
y para mí el punto de vista muy personal
yo considero que la estabilidad del
sistema financiero costarricense hoy no
está preparada ojo totalmente para
soportar una crisis financiera sistémica
sin que haya pérdidas fiscales
considerables especialmente porque hay
una garantía ilimitada de los depósitos
en favor de ciertos intermediarios y si
no entendemos el caso pues ahí está el
banco crédito agrícola que le ha costado
al ministerio de hacienda el banco más
pequeño 133 mil millones de colones que
si no se fusiona con el banco de costa
rica irían a sumar al déficit fiscal que
hoy tenemos que nuestra señora
contralora lo mencionó el déficit fiscal
97.2 es 7.5 por las pérdidas actuales de
ese rescate financiero del banco crédito
ahora todos sabemos que un sistema
financiero sus cimientos sólidos la
estructura sólida se construye sobre dos
principios básicos confianza y
credibilidad no nos podemos dar el lujo
en la coyuntura actual que se pierda la
confianza en alguno de los
intermediarios no importa si su carácter
es financiero si su carácter es bursátil
por el 'efecto contagio' que esto tiene
en el resto del sistema
temas como la liquidez a propósito de
los acontecimientos de los últimos meses
una buena gobernanza la calidad de los
sistemas de información la capacidad
experiencia conocimiento de las juntas
directivas y de la alta administración
una visión responsable e integral del
manejo de los riesgos operativos de
crédito los riesgos de mercado son
elementos mandatorios que así como
existen en la construcción en el código
sísmico deberían ser parte de la
estructura fundamental del sistema
financiero es sin ninguna duda
yo voy a proceder ahora a hacer una
serie de señalamientos sobre las
debilidades que en distintos estudios
sean identificados sin ser exhaustivo
pero si haciendo un repaso de donde creo
yo que urge tomar las medidas para
solidificar la estructura de este
edificio que llamamos el sistema
financiero
lo primero la supervisión vean yo viví
en el sector financiero 30 años y
reconozco que ha habido avances
significativos en la calidad de la
supervisión en general del país pero
cuando uno compara el sistema de
supervisión costarricense con las
mejores prácticas internacionales se da
cuenta que aún nuestros supervisores
carecen de las herramientas totales para
poder identificar tempranamente los
riesgos y para poder minimizar y
resolver ágilmente los problemas
entonces ahí yo creo que hay que
trabajar más sobre la resolución de
problemas y sobre las herramientas que
tengan los supervisores de actuación
en segundo lugar hemos hemos dado un
gran paso se ha cambiado el enfoque de
la supervisión hoy se llama supervisión
basada en riesgos en el pasado nosotros
no se evaluaban en función del camp el
ahora que estaba practicando dije esto
mis roberto y ese y eso quería entonces
el cambio bueno es el sistema que
existía antes para medir para calificar
a los intermediarios ahora nos estamos
pasando a una supervisión basada en
riesgos que para mí gusto su
implementación ha sido más lenta de lo
que uno quisiera en segundo lugar creo
que hace falta una mayor coordinación
entre las cuatro superintendencias creo
que hace falta una visión de bosque de
los grupos financieros y creo también
que hay que incorporar necesariamente el
rol del banco central como ente rector
de la normativa macroprudencial y hay
que definir los territorios las
competencias que le toca cada una de
esas partes yo creo que ahí hay tarea
todavía que hacer aunque repito el
camino va bien encaminado
y yo tengo que decirles en carne propia
esto lo viví por eso puse esa lámina 10
y 11 de agosto del año 2004
estoy hablando prácticamente de hace 20
años
cuando con base en un rumor infundado
casi nos quiebran en aquel momento el
back y por eso yo llego a concluir que
incluso hoy la red de seguridad
financiera que tiene el sistema es
incompleta y es insuficiente arrancando
por lo que se llama el prestamista de
última instancia o lo que se llama
técnicamente el redescuento cuando
estábamos nosotros de media tormenta
nosotros tratamos de hacer uso de los
préstamos de emergencia que hace el
banco central a través del re descuento
primero dice el reglamento tienen que
convocar a un comité de tres personas
para determinar si efectivamente el
banco está en una crisis de liquidez y
los que hemos pasado por ahí verdad uno
sabe que cada minuto es oro en segundo
lugar si concluyeron ese comité que
efectivamente habían problemas liquidez
tienen que empezar a pedir las garantías
que califican para el descuento con la
sorpresa de que solamente son garantías
reales hipotecarias y de créditos de
corto plazo
y en colones todos los que estamos en
esta actividad sabemos que ese fenómeno
es quizás el más escaso y por lo tanto
para mí el redescuento no funciona sé
que desde el año 2004 la asociación
bancaria costarricense le planteó al
banco central la creación de un
mecanismo alterno de préstamos de
emergencia y hace un par de semanas
salió 20 años después el reglamento
sobre esa instancia pero aún no se han
hecho las pruebas operativas una cosa es
graduarse con honores de natación en una
pizarra y la otra cosa es aprender a
nadar cuando a uno lo tiran a la piscina
simplemente se ahoga y hay que hacer las
pruebas desde a quien llamó todos los
teléfonos de la casa del celular de la
novia de la esposa verdad de las
autoridades correspondientes esto es un
trabajo 24/7 de la crisis puede suceder
sucederá cualquier minuto y por lo tanto
tiene que haber esa comunicación fluida
entre los distintos participantes por
otro lado el banco central lleva yo
diría años décadas desarrollando un
proyecto de ley de seguro de depósitos y
de resolución de problemas que sigue sin
salir en cuanto a los planes de pensión
estatales de beneficio definido hay n
estudios actuariales que demuestran que
esos planes tienen debilidades
fundamentales y que no son sostenibles a
largo plazo a alguien se enteró de que
ayudar a esta charla y ayer en la nación
salió el plan de pensiones del hice para
sí como ese hay otra serie de planes de
beneficio definido que tienen que sufrir
ajustes en sus parámetros para que sean
sostenibles en el largo plazo que es lo
que ha sucedido
incluso ha habido movimientos para
evitar que la supervisión trabaje sobre
ellos y eso se ha llevado incluso a los
estratos judiciales la polarización es
un fenómeno que causa el riesgo de
liquidez y riesgos de solvencia del
sistema más aún cuando ya no solamente
los clientes sino también los mismos
agentes participantes consideran que el
riesgo cambiario en este país es nulo o
es muy bajo porque el banco central
rescata porque el banco central
interviene porque el banco central
mantiene un tipo de cambio nominal
artificialmente bajo tanto así que en
los últimos cuatro años la devaluación
promedio anual de este país fue punto 8%
hoy hay 800.000 familias costarricenses
endeudadas en dólares sin tener
capacidad de generar dólares hoy el 40
por ciento de la deuda del gobierno
central está en dólares
hoy los pasivos de las entidades
autónomas en su mayoría están en dólares
por lo tanto este riesgo es latente y yo
difiero de lo que se ha tomado como
estrategia en los últimos años que es
satanizar los dólares no es posible que
teniendo inflación es de un dígito la
tasa promedio de préstamos en colones de
este país siga siendo 16 por ciento unas
tasas reales bestiales porque no se ha
trabajado en la eficiencia de la
intermediación en la competencia de la
intermediación en colones
en mi opinión la exposición de riesgo de
los intermediarios bursátiles de los
intermediarios financieros de las
compañías de seguros de los portafolios
individuales en bonos soberanos
costarricenses se nos ha ido la mano
asegúrese de tener este diversificación
que no todos los huevos estén en la
misma canasta pero mi abuela también me
decía y asegúrese que no solamente estén
en huevos hemos pecado solamente de ver
la tasa de interés que nos pagan los
bonos del gobierno de costa rica y nos
hemos olvidado del riesgo claro si hay
un problema de liquidez y dios no lo
quiera un problema de insolvencia pues
obviamente como sistema vamos a sufrir
en cuanto a las deudas de las familias
resulta que los intermediarios
financieros sólo tienen una versión una
visión parcial del apalancamiento de las
familias que es la central de
información de deudores donde no se
registran las deudas con
los créditos comerciales ni tampoco se
registran ahí las deudas cada vez
mayores del sistema informal y eso hace
que junto con una política a mi criterio
a veces irresponsable de los
intermediarios que tiran a sus fuerzas
de ventas a nadar marketshare ya colocar
nuestras familias hoy estén en exceso
endeudadas y por último no tenemos una
estrategia nacional de inclusión y de
alfabetización financiera sé que hay
esfuerzos individuales que hay que
reconocer importantes pero esto es un
problema nacional que debería estar en
el plan nacional de desarrollo qué es lo
que sucede nuestro ciudadano común no
tiene la capacidad de calcular una tasa
de interés efectiva para ver cuántos
realmente le están cobrando en el
financiamiento sino que a lo sumo bueno
dígame cuánto lo que tengo que pagar por
mes en esa pantalla high definition me
alcanza no me casa me la llevo me la
juego pero no sabe cuál es la tasa de
interés que se le está cobrando
y por último el medio de pago preferido
sigue siendo el efectivo tanto así que
todos sabemos que hay incluso no
solamente en las familias sino si
ciertos sectores comerciales que manejan
grandes masas de efectivo no hay
transparencia no hay trazabilidad fiscal
y nos genera un costo operativo que en
mis tiempos lo habíamos calculado de 500
millones de dólares anuales casi la
reforma fiscal que está pretendiendo
pasarse hoy se ahorraría si tuviéramos
una fecha donde el banco central nos
dice desapareció el uso del efectivo
vamos a la modernidad el pago
electrónico como existe ya en los países
asiáticos y en otros países europeos
bueno yo sé que ha sido bastante ácido
álgido señalando las debilidades de la
estructura pero quisiera concluir mi
presentación diciendo hay soluciones hay
soluciones no es que esto no se pueda
resolver y entonces quisiera dar algunas
sugerencias de solución obviamente lo
primero es crear una comisión mixta de
reformas financieras en asamblea
legislativa con la participación de las
autoridades técnica
que conocen de esta materia yo he pasado
por la asamblea legislativa y les puedo
decir que el conocimiento financiero de
las personas que están ahí es mínimo
sino nulo por lo tanto es necesario que
los entes técnicos se involucren y
participen en esta comisión mixta desde
el año 1995 no existe en el país una
comisión de reformas financieras en
segundo lugar se requiere un rol más
activo del banco central el banco
central tiene que marcar la cancha tiene
que ir ahí al congreso tiene que
defender sus posiciones para que se
apruebe la ley de supervisión
consolidada para que se aprueben la ley
de seguro de depósitos y resolución de
problemas para que se apruebe la ley de
idoneidad y experiencia de las juntas
directivas y de la alta administración
de los bancos para que se apruebe la
protección legal de los supervisores si
los entes técnicos no están marcando la
cancha encuesta demoras nada sale
simplemente los proyectos se archivan
y hay que implementar ahora que estamos
en condiciones normales el mecanismo
este de préstamos de emergencia o de
última instancia vean cuando uno está
metido en el vendaval en la tormenta
elementos como el siguiente a no no te
puedo dar colones porque la gente quiere
efectivo porque la bóveda del banco
central se abre automáticamente y se
abre a partir de la 9 de la mañana y yo
le ofrecí a la gente que a partir de las
7 de la mañana podrían ir a reponer el
efectivo a cualquier sucursal del back
yo no sé si todavía la bóveda del banco
central automática se abre a las nueve
de la mañana o ya tiene apertura a
cualquier momento hasta esos elementos
específicos son importantes a la hora
que estamos en el vendaval y finalmente
hay que modificar el reglamento de la
central de información de deudores para
incorporar tanto el crédito informal
financiero como el crédito comercial
porque son fuentes también de riesgo
sistémico quisiera concluir mi
presentación que soy optimista como
decía winston churchill un pesimista ve
una amenaza en cada oportunidad por el
contrario un optimista ve una
oportunidad en cada
amenaza creo que yo he sido tal vez un
poco excesivo en mi presentación porque
dicen por ahí mis abuelos que el que se
quema con leche hasta la cuajada sopla
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]